lady gaga
Selena Gomez and Jimmy Levada were
amongst the honorees this morning in New
York as Billboard Magazine's saluted the
top women and music and our car lease
deal with in the middle of the
celebration let's recap your week Grammy
nomination Golden Globe nomination Woman
of the Year pretty good we a good week
it has been a really good week I'm just
so very very lucky girl this year to
have people really believe in me Lady
Gaga's Golden Globes nom for American
Horror Story hotel got a huge reaction
from her fiance Taylor Kinney phobics
his reaction to your Golden Globe
nomination he was so excited he was
screaming on the phone we were both
laughing we're both very very excited
and her Grammy Nam is for this
until it happens to you is a song Gaga
co-wrote about being raped as a 19 year
old you're so amazingly open with your
fans sharing your experiences why is
that so important for you well I think
that that's how you change the world as
a person you know no matter who you are
you change the world by sharing your
stories with other people for amazing
courage is one of the reasons she is
billboards Woman of the Year for 2015
also being honored Selena Gomez who
tells us forget those 1d rumors all the
fans want to know can we set the record
straight Niall you guys know I love him
I always have an ask for though that
Demi Willmar marriage rumors some of
your fans seem to think you and Wilmer
are secretly married is that true Mel
we're definitely not secretly could
choose 2016 be a potential engagement
year for you you gotta add Kim I have no
idea